they were seeking safety elsewhere but
had to flee kabul airport to save
themselves
a suicide bomber claimed the lives of so
many here
and killed even more hopes and dreams
but even this catastrophic attack hasn't
deterred people
in their desperation they've moved to a
different entrance
but the gates are now closed along with
their window for evacuation
and there's an ongoing threat that is
may strike again
foreign
medics worked through the night treating
casualties in kabul's hospitals one man
caught up in the attack with his
children is not prepared to risk it
again
speaking to me from kabul he described
how he was trying to help his sisters
get home to australia they're now stuck
i almost like shocked because i didn't
see what i i never wanted to see in my
whole life i was just
seeing people like laying down and
many of them in jurors many of them lost
their lives kids
women men
as the final evacuation flights leave
with the final few thousand afghan
families are burying their dead
those people who feared for their lives
lost them trying to flee to safety
afghans evacuated to qatar are
devastated by the news
this ngo worker still can't get hold of
friends who were at the airport at the
time of the attack we're waiting you
know for some way to get in touch with
them at least if we could have access to
internet we would have you know been in
contact with them that what's happening
to them most of them are very hopeless
two days ago i had a chance to come
online and i spoke with them so they are
saying that we have nothing we feel that
we are caged i feel lucky that i you
know got out of afghanistan at such a
point that everybody is you know waiting
and willing to come out of afghanistan
but my heart still remains there because
i i see that millions of people are
stuck they are not happy with whatever
happened with the coming of taliban
nobody is happy
the so-called peace settlement hammered
out in qatar focused on troop withdrawal
but the threat of isis k could be the
greatest challenge of all to the
incoming taliban government and who
knows what that means for the afghan
people
after nearly two weeks of absolute chaos
in kabul more than a hundred thousand
people have now been evacuated from
afghanistan many of them through doha
but in the closing days of this 20-year
war on terror an attack has killed more
than 100 people including 13 u.s service
personnel
and qatar is likely to be a key player
in brokering the next uncertain chapter
for afghanistan
now with evacuations in their final
hours people are still risking their
lives to try and leave
whether it's the resilience of afghans
or lack of anything to lose
sally lockwood sky news doha